joining us now from the Sporting News
national college football writer it's
bill bender on the Rich Eisen show hi
Bill how are you I'm doing well Andrew
thanks for having me on hey thank you
for for coming on there are there only
so many games it's not like last week
where you had four games on at 8 o'clock
Eastern or 7:30 Eastern and you couldn't
figure out what to watch your head was
gonna blow up this is a little bit
different though we do have two really
good late ones the number three Clemson
number 14 Louisville game is the one
most people are circling and there are
some people notably some people that
work on this show build that think Lamar
Jackson could put a stranglehold hold on
a high ceman this week are you one of
those people it seems like he could
either win or lose it tomorrow night I
mean it with a win they become the team
to beat in the ACC he's probably gonna
have 300 400 500 yards who knows in that
win and they make a statement that way
and he probably takes the lead over I
think Baker Mayfield the leader right
now but based on a six day curve and
then if they lose it'll just go back to
last year where they're like he lost the
last three games they're not gonna win
the ACC he can be a placeholder in New
York but he can't win the thing and
that's dangerous thinking but I think
that's where we're at right now hey you
mentioned Baker Mayfield film why do you
have to apologize I don't know I would
know what's the big deal you know I mean
it was fun and he owned that game I saw
that you know that that game last week
he just played he was best player on the
field he earned it
he was probably hearing some things from
fans but a high state can bounce back
from that it's not so much I think the
flag planning actually overshadowed what
a great game he played and what a great
game Lincoln Riley called there in Ohio
Stadium that's a tough place to go in at
night yeah for those who don't know and
you can't see it on the TV Baker
Mayfield came out early in the week and
apologized for for planting that öyou
flag at the middle of the field in
Columbus of the horseshoe after they
just kind of dominated Ohio State and
then look we knew they were good and
they have a new coach obviously things
change quickly they were linked into the
offseason but I'm not linking I'm sorry
in Norman but I don't know why he had to
apologize I'd be more concerned if I'm
State fan bill what's wrong with my team
well it's the same problems they've had
the last few years it's finding a deeper
I don't even think it's finding a deep
ferret receiver anymore I think it's
just finding some cohesion in the
passing game they've always been able to
run under the mire they kind of abandon
the run a little bit I think Oklahoma
dared them to throw by stacking the Box
a little bit so it's a function of de
Barrett's got to be better the receivers
got to find some separation they need
better play calling and they have a
stretch now what army UNLV Rutgers
Maryland where they can get it together
but they better have something better
than what they showed against Oklahoma
when Penn State comes to town and above
bill bender from the sporting news on
the Rich Eisen show I'm Andrew Siciliano
in for Rich you can follow bill by the
way at bill bender 92 bill bender 92 on
on the Twitter bill what do you make of
what Cardale Jones was tweeting during
the game during that Ohio State loss you
know blame the coaches here JT you know
I they they couldn't run me to death
like JT whatever it was I don't know
much I mean Ohio State former players
have a lot of pride in that school and
you know when you're at a school where
you've only lost seven games since the
Urban Meyer took over I mean what
program wouldn't take that I I've said
for a couple years now I think Alabama
and Ohio State are the only schools that
truly believe they should they should
win every game in theory they're gonna
be favored every game I would almost
want Clemson Clemson into that net
conversation now but yeah every time a
hyoe state loses there's an equal and
way bigger overreaction that follows
bill are you buying USC after what they
did to Stanford last week certainly I
think they can use that I mean it's it's
kind of the same reaction that we were
having when they kind of messed around
with Western Michigan a little bit but
Sam Donald the real deal I think there
are three quarterbacks in college
football right now that can get you to
the playoff on that and not on their own
but you know what I mean kind of lead a
team to the class and I think it's Baker
Mayfield say I'm darn 'old and Lamar
Jackson and that's why it's kind of
Lamar Jackson stage tomorrow but USC has
a lot of work to do particularly this
month they got to take care of business
against Texas I think they will and then
they've got back-to-back road games at
Cal and Washington State
now Washington State Friday night game
at the end of the month is gonna be real
interesting with darn 'old and uh Luke
fault because you know mike leach he
won't he'll throw a hundred passes if he
has to try to win that game yeah in the
firt and in the first quarter Luke Falk
by the way by the end of the year likely
passes Sean Mannion and becomes the the
leading passer impact 12 history there
are other quarterbacks though there's
Josh Allen Wyoming gets Oregon this week
there are at last check 16 NFL teams
credentialed to watch that one and watch
Josh Allen and then there's UCLA on the
road at Memphis we know what Josh Rosen
has done in the first couple of weeks
bill you know we're kicking this around
before I think and listen neither
neither kid has applied for the draft
yet I work for the league I am NOT
suggesting here that I know where
anyone's gonna go but but but look we
all know that these two quarterbacks
darn old and Rosen could come out
I think Rosen would be better suited if
it's the Jets at number one just for New
York and Arnold I'm not saying he's a
better player I just think the the Josh
Rosen I don't care what you say about me
attitude would be awesome to watch and
listen and see every day in New York he
can play too yeah that's not bad yeah if
he got there and won a little bit it
could backfire if he goes there and
things go south it's an interesting game
for them tomorrow I think they're gonna
win but yeah you know it's tricky
everybody's gonna make everything about
the early kick-off and all those kind of
things but he's playing so well right
now and that Texas A&M game was a
springboard I get what you're saying I'd
rather have darn 'old personally but
that's not to say Rosen with the media
with the pressure with everything that
comes there and a guy that it's so rare
these days as you know I mean these
college guys get so they're so I don't
know what the word is secured and kind
of kept on a leash that he's one of the
few that says what's on his mind and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
it he's not he's never said anything
outright bad about college football over
the last three years know and you could
complain about what he said yeah I don't
care who you I know who you would be
what he said about academics and what he
said was right and and and for the
record that that interview I'm pretty
sure was given months ago Josh Rosen
as has toed the line this year he has
said the right things he is maturing if
you want to if you want to put it that
way he was always amazingly mature but
he is he's understanding I think how to
play the game off the field more so than
then we saw the first couple of years
and I'm not suggesting when I say that
Rosen would be the better fit for New
York that darn old somehow can't handle
pressure because he he has shown that he
can handle pressure
I say Kwan Barclay is he is he good
enough from the people you talk to bill
to continue in that line of now two
running backs going in the top five yeah
I think college football I mean I know
there's quarterbacks that's a separate
discussion almost but if he's the best
player in a big ten I'll start there and
you watch that game last week they were
kind of in a funk offensively then he
runs and zipper out down the seam sorely
hit some 46-yard touchdown game over I'm
running backs like him just I haven't
seen many with that kind of burst but he
has he can get for every time has a
chance to carry Penn State to a Big Ten
championship and I know it's hard guys
will get lazy and they lump him in with
the Kijana Carter z-- and some of those
busts but Penn State's had in the draft
but he's special I think he's worth the
top five pick and I mean if you like
Ezekiel Elliott you're gonna love to
take home Berkeley - yeah bill one more
thing here and this may sound crazy feel
free to tell me I'm nuts should Nick
Eason be worried about his job yeah I
mean it can happen from played well in
the spring and if he keeps winning keeps
Georgia in that SMC's
talent who knows what Kirby smart will
do from from an excellent quarterback in
there's no reason why I think September
30th is an interesting target date for
Georgia because they're gonna be
undefeated if they beat Mississippi
State and they're gonna be playing
Tennessee there's gonna be a lot on the
line in the SEC East I'm anxious to
watch for to Tennessee we didn't get
really touch on that because the Florida
loses they're out and it kind of C wins
it sets up a big showdown at the end of
the mark alright for those who don't
know I was just reminded Thank You Don
Nicki's and the Georgia quarterback who
obviously was heard in the Appalachian
State game week one he did not play last
week but they still
when in and one in South Bend and
actually bill I lied one last thing your
thoughts on Brian Kelly's end of
postgame press conference last week my
thought lakyn asked a fair question she
have an excellent job and the exchange
went too long and then at that point you
kind of knew BK was gonna get upset and
he did a one point loss is still one
score loss and and at the end of the day
that's gonna be what defines that team
or defines his exit they've got to start
winning close game they're a good
football team they've got a lot of
talent especially on the offensive side
but we're gonna know a lot more where b
ches headed i think when they play
michigan state up in east lansing here
in two weeks i mean interesting game
last year i thought that game would
matter a lot more than it did this year
i think it matters but for a few
different reasons
absolutely look notre dame at home there
there felt like more georgia fans and
that's an exaggeration but it felt like
a 50-50 crowd watching on TV and people
that were there will tell you the same
thing that's a huge win for georgia
going north of the mason-dixon and it's
one of those ones where you knew it's
gonna be tough if you're a Notre Dame
fan but just the way everything
transpired probably makes makes it even
more uncomfortable moving forward this
year bill bender from the Sporting News
follow him at bill bender 92 on the
Twitter bill good to finally talk man
thanks for coming on and enjoy your
football this weekend any time thanks
for having y'all appreciate it you got
it go bender there of the Sporting News
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches